>> Okay, Michael, what's your answer?
>> Alright. So. Again, a lot feels like a good
answer, it's already written down on the left. But it's
also wait, wait, may be we can quantify this. So
if it were. Maybe one way to think about this
is if each of the, each of those empty boxes
there, is either true or false. It's kind of like a
bit. And we're asking how many different bit patterns can
we make? And in general, it's two to the number
of positions, but here the number of positions is 2 to the n. So it ought to
be 2, to the 2 to the n. Which is that the same as 4 to the n?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> But you're right. It's 2 to the 2
to the n. So it's a double exponential and
it's not the same thing as 4 to the nth. It's actually 2 to the 2 to the nth.
Now how big of a number do you think that is Michael?
>> I'm going to go again to my go to place and just say a lot.
>> It is, in fact, a lot and I'm
going, I actually, I'm going to look over here, and I'm
going to tell you. That for even a small value
of n, this gets to be a really big number.
>> So for, for one, it's 2 to the 2
to the 1, which is 4. That's not a big number.
>> That's true. What about two?
>> For
two, it's 2 to the 2 to the 2. So 2 to
the 2 is 4, so it's 2 to the 4, which is 16.
>> What about three?
>> Alright, so that's two to the 8th, which is 256?
>> Mm-hm. So that's growing pretty fast, don't you think?
>> Sure, but those aren't big numbers yet.
>> What if I told you, [LAUGH] that for n equals
6, 2 to the 2 to the n was, I'm going to start
writing it, okay? 18466744073709551616.
>> Holy monkeys.
>> Yes, that is in fact the technical term for this number,
it's a holy monkey. It is a very, very big number.
So 2 to the n grows very fast. We already called
that evil. 2 to the 2 to the n is a
double exponential and it's super evil. It grows very, very, very,
very, very fast. So what's the point of this exercise, Michael?
It's, it's to point that the space of decision trees, the
hypothesis space that we've chosen, is very expressive because there's lots
of different functions that you can represent. But that also means
we have to have some clever way to search
among them. And that gets us back to our
notion of an algorithm with actually going to very
smartly go through and pick out which decision tree. Because
if we aren't very smart about it and we
start eliminating whole decision trees along the way. Then we're
going to have to look it to billions upon, billions
upon, billions upon, billion upon, billion of possible decision choice.